the world had like a twoe freakout with
gp4 right this changes everything AGI is
coming tomorrow there are no jobs by the
end of the year and now people are like
why is it so
slow
um and I love that I think that's a
great thing about the human spirit that
we always want more and better and I
think that's why we're never going to
run out of things to do
gp4 was a big deal in some sense and did
not change the world as much as
everybody had their meltdown about I
believe that some day we will make
something that qualifies as an AGI by
whatever fuzzy definition you want the
world will have a twoe freakout and then
people will go on with their lives we
are making a tool that is impressive but
humans are going to do their human
things and Society has a lot of inertia
and I think like we will both invent AGI
sooner than most of the world thinks and
in those first few years it will change
the world much less and then the long
term it'll change it more